what's going on guys welcome to I think
v AWS or just VPS web server tutorial
where we left off I was just showing you
guys that it's kind of hard to run these
two things simultaneously so how do we
actually run them at the same time as
each other what you can do is say you
want to do Python running to that pi you
can run in the background with the N
sign right there and so I guess it's
really called the Ibrahim anyway so now
it's running and it looks like almost
the same thing we saw before like if I
said py too you can see how it's kind of
like running over our text well if I hit
ctrl C I can't break the script right so
it is running in the background
but it's kind of spamming at us but you
just kind of need to ignore the spam
because it's just printing the console
so if you had a program you would just
not print to console maybe but anyway so
we're running tests to in the in the
background so now we can go python
running one pi it's very hard to type
this out and we'll hit enter and now you
can see we're running them both right
we're printing out python 1 or test 1
test 2 test 1 test 2 but test 1 python 1
is running in the foreground so when we
hit control C and keyboard interrupt
that one stops but test 2 continues
running now the same thing though we can
go python running 1 dot hi ampersand go
and now the right they're both running
in the background right well you can
bring them to the foreground with FG
right and so now we can keyboard
interrupt at least that wine let's see
if we can catch to Australia that Union
there we go so now they're both stopped
so that's how you can run them
two scripts or multiple scripts at the
same time as each other obviously it's
pretty annoying when you're printing
stuff out like that but that's really
not necessary you don't need to be
printing out to console the other thing
that you can do and you'll either
incorporate it with in your script have
a log file that just prints out
everything that it does or you can
actually program in to have a log file
and what I'm about to show you is going
to log it by default as well so anyway
that's how you can get scripts to run
simultaneously but the problem with this
is when your user goes to log out if you
log out these programs will cease to run
luckily there is a way around that and
that's what I'm gonna be showing you
guys in the next video so as always
thanks for watching thanks for your
support
descriptions and until next time